this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and today we're
talking about the early-season outbreak
of dollar spot that we're experiencing
the persistent wet weather now with the
warm nighttime temperatures grass very
lush from that spring surge of growth
especially the higher cut turf we're not
seeing as much on putting greens but the
higher cut turf and approaches and
fairways key areas are experiencing a
lot more dollar spot than we would
normally see at this time so the best
thing to think about now is obviously to
get some of your early season
protections down maybe the pressure is
not so bad you might go with softer
chemicals like emerald civitas or
consider early season applications to
cure land there's a number of studies
that have shown those early season
applications can reduce overall pet
overall fungicide use for dollar spot
but also consider that you've got to
recover so make sure your nitrogen
fertility is adequate and that you're
able to get some recovery into these
areas and once you start thinking about
sort of getting on this right away
before you get epidemic levels a dollar
spot you should be able to work your way
right through it without any loss in
quality or performance this Frank Rossi
for the Cornell turfgrass video log this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu